it's time for the lawn Jean Chronicle a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and fridays a
presentation of the lawn jean wit nor
watch company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon Jean good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
Jean chrono scope from the CBS
television news staff Larry lasseur and
Ned calmar our distinguished guest for
this evening is the honorable Karl
Gruber Austrian ambassador to the United
States dr. Kruger you were a member of
the Austrian resistance movement during
the war and you've been involved in its
foreign policy ever since now the big
for Western powers have met at least 400
times discuss the terms of a peace
treaty for Austria the one that was
promised ten years ago and nothing has
happened you feel discouraged about it
why my on to the depth is no I do not
feel discouraged i do not see an
immediate prospect of a deity but you
see we have a history of almost a
thousand years naseeba can survive a few
radical doctrine's true want to come
tips well when we accepted the terms for
the an Austrian peace treaty I think
that was 1943 mr. Molotov refused at
that time to do any more about it then
at Berlin we accepted the terms the
Russian terms for an Austrian peace
treaty and mr. Molotov refused to go
along with that now do you feel that
this means the end of the whole thing
well first I want to say this was a very
good diplomatic moved from your site
because they had to show their hands now
declared quite openly that even if you
sign the proposed treaty which they
proposed I want to say it would not be
ready to go so this ends one phase of
the title making but there are more to
come I think we have not to drop hope
for the next future what do you mean in
other words at these 375 or three and
eighty meetings meant actually nothing
because we accepted all the Russian
terms and they show their actual
and they must keep troops in Austria
does that mean that an Austrian peace
treaty is dependent upon a settlement
with Germany useful web apps not accept
on Germany but apparently they want to
use Oscar as a pawn in the overall game
and as long as we have not much more
development between east and west I
think we cannot expect any sudden
development but I'm quite hope for the
time will come where they were think
again about the policy and then I think
we will get our treaty dr. group of the
Soviet policy now seems to be the
scrapping of the European defense plan
which would include Germany in its army
you feel that they succeeded in
scrapping that the EDC as we call it
they would then sign an Austrian peace
treaty well you never know you say they
said very often if you fulfill this
condition of every sign it lady and then
we take this and then they came as
something you so you never can predict
and they would not be too sure what they
do if this condition is really then well
mr. ambassador out the Austrians getting
a little bit weary of living under
Soviet rule occupation how long has this
been going on now what is going on since
the end of divorce you know and
certainly fed up visitors no doubt about
that do the Russians make themselves
objectionable have they changed in that
period of occupation where they changed
a little bit they did at least a better
dressing of the window but they still
run 300 factories by their Russian
management and the exploratory oil so
there's quite a great train on our
economy well does that change the
traditional gay life of Vienna at all
don't do much shell of the matter
luckily enough of you nice effort great
these passive strings and they keep to
the habits along the lines of that I
might ask you dr. drew but what do you
people do in the traditional coffee
houses of the NF a coffee now well you
see they try to get good coffee still no
this little bit more expensive as before
the war but you're quite happy there I
see well it's Denny Moscow has now
proposed that Russia be invited to join
the the NATO pact which is an
anti-communist packed and they've also
proposed of course that the United
States be allowed to join their
pan-european security service system and
any think that's a propaganda move or
should we take it seriously well I have
not seen the text yet so I would like to
reserve my comment but for my past
experiences I would not immediately
start too great an optimism on it but
you don't think that that proposal would
have any reaction on the future of
Austria well I don't see any immediate
result of it I think we have to wait
what further the right to what proof
they were discouraged about the about
the future of Austria it seems to me
that the Trieste problem over which
Italy and Yugoslavia are embroiled also
affects Austria does it not where we
have certainly very strong economic
interests there because this is the port
where we really export most of our trade
and for this reason we are interested at
first there's good order and not any
major trouble between Italy and
Yugoslavia and at our economic interests
they are protected because you might
remember this this Harbor was developed
in the Austin time and we still feel
very friendly to the people on the hope
that the settlement will be reached
whereby we can keep our interests corner
dr. drew very get along with your other
communist neighbors with Hungary with
Poland with Czechoslovakia you have much
trade with them well our trade dropped
considerably we had forty percent of our
whole foreign trade went to the east
before the war it's now down to ten
percent there's still some trait and we
need some day there's no doubt because
you cannot embrace fifty percent of your
trade in such a short time but the whole
thing is not too easy to conduct because
you know this is bought by a policy
whereby they have sealed off the
volunteers and so it's not so
perspective for the next future well if
Austria has lost her key recidivist
trade how do you manage to live there
why we replaced it by trade in all
directions which was not easy to do but
luckily enough we could manage at least
to replace some of this trade by all the
directions now anta creation of the
European payments union which was a
result of the Marshall Plan as you might
remember litigate was a great help in
this respect at that grew by no you left
us
actually right after they on tourists
with Nazi Germany but cutting I ask you
a personal question do you think that
Austria is a viable political body can
it survive without a nuanced list with
Germany and its trade in its industry
well I would say this I mean any country
can live if the others are ready to let
it live so the life of us more country
or middle of a middle-sized country but
always get bent about general diet
system you can set up and a single state
has certainly enough resources to be why
ever and we would be very hope for as
soon as they political trouble are
settled for all state and I think your
company's in a position to survive but
do you have any internal troubles as
your domestic political life in Austria
mentally stable we have not too much
dowry always have frictions there might
be in any human institution but I think
the Russians keep us together it's the
Russians in keeping illness I take it
that you don't have any communist
problem internally in Austria sir
practically none because buying three
elections narviat less than five percent
of homeless in our country well dr.
Gruber in 1943 the Russians promised
that Austria would be regarded as a
liberated country occupied by the
Germans and after the war they never
agreed to this liberation policy anymore
and they still occupy Austria how do you
feel this was marked a change in their
policy well I can't see me a great
change they had always let the bar is in
Ostia of the status quo that means they
are not too unpleasant on the whole but
they want to keep the top stair and keep
the military position and they are not
likely to change this policy if there
are no major considerations in other
fields which you can easily see as a
result of the burning conference now how
are they getting along on the famous
international patrol in Vienna the four
men in a Jeep is still running around
still running
and I think they please keep a fair
amount of understanding between them but
dr. Gruber why do you suppose the
Russians have acted differently in
Austria than they have in Germany we
haven't the trouble erotic clashes
between East and West Germany that there
that there haven't got those clashes in
Austria now what do you suppose that has
happened this whole climate seems to be
quite different there well there are
many reasons that would be quite a long
story to tell about one of the main
reasons is this the right from the
beginning we had central austin
government who kept the country together
and one currency and then I think the
whole policy was a little bit different
connector concerning German in
concerning Austria and also they just
want to keep it let's say as a military
bases and they barely not inventions to
create it as a direct satellite of the
Russian Empire on you feel that there is
no intention then of partition of
Austria at any time by the Soviet Union
no well do you feel that do you feel
there that you would like the Western
Allies to leave the country also but not
certainly not alone I mean not before
the Russians has gone out I mean that
certainly would be against though well
there was no demand from the population
that the foreign troops leave Austria
now well if they leave then they should
leave together and should leave if there
are lost Russians or just get out and I
hope you happy when other school but not
to sing your day before that I ask you
sir how the Austrian people now feel
about the people over here in America oh
very funny I think you certainly will
find that in our country at least the
great help it you have given to our
people at got results and you will find
them very friendly disclosed and this is
a lasting friendship I can assure you
mr. Messner I may ask you the final
question do you feel that the tensions
which now exists in the world the
international tensions are relaxing or
are they getting worse how do you feel
they they are tending towards the future
of Austria that's certainly hard to say
because we have reached a stationary
situation in Europe at least not where
there
great changes on frontiers and on
regions between east and west in the
last months or years and so it depends
much all the other issues might turn out
it's still critical little dangerous but
we hope you see overseeing optimism is
as costly as best amusement for this
reason I'm an optimist what do you think
we're moving towards a negotiating stage
we have a lot of international
conferences set up I'm thinking
particularly the one at Geneva well I
would say we move to a talking stage
which doesn't mean that we are moving to
a negotiating stage this is much clearly
the church now but thank you very much
traffic / privilege to have you here
tonight the opinions expressed on the
lawn Jane krona scope were those of the
speakers the editorial board for this
edition of the launch in chrono scope
was Larry lisseur and Ned calmar our
distinguished guest was the Honorable
Karl Gruber Austrian ambassador to the
United States